hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba hey
MCC how they see Howard you are in some
ways the Harley Quinn of the real
rejects yes I'm just trying to make this
seem seamless in his transition hey
Stacy I hear that there's this festival
going on [ __ ] yeah it's a hosted by like
Leonard Maltin and Jesse yes and Alice
multitude the Maltin family guys I was
IMing Moulton fest legendary film critic
been doing it for decades I mean he is
the man with the plan
the Oh G is now throwing a film festival
for film nerds this isn't Hollywood May
10th through 12th at the legendary
Egyptian theater it's gonna be some
special guests including Doug Benson Joe
Dante Holly Payne we're gonna have
feature films documentaries short films
this is hidden gems things you may have
missed spanning decades and decades in
Hollywood we're so excited to have
everyone join us the weekend badges are
on sale right now at Leonard Maltin comm
slash Maltin fest so check it out super
excited we're gonna announce all the
special guests the slate of films that
we have coming up it's gonna be
incredible a ton of bang for your buck
lots of options and it's gonna be a good
time I like banging for bucks let's do
this Stacy we're gonna watch The Joker
its concept trailer right this isn't a
real trailer but man I cannot tell you
how many subscribers have been like you
got to check out this concept trailer I
imagine they probably infused some of
the real test footage in here or
something like that and I just we just
happen to be filming a Captain Marvel
review that's why I'm wearing a MCU
shirt right now exactly I'm sure this is
a not upsetting for the DC fan base at
all Stacy you should have changed your
pin yeah it's like real footage damage
that
[Music]
[Music]
and this isn't real footage but he's
nice
[Applause]
[Music]
have you seen those like Nicolas Cage
freaking out compilations someone should
make that for Joaquin Phoenix I mean I
feel like this is one of them yeah I
gotta say the editor of what he used you
ever edited this thing when they use the
footage from the like the Joker - yes
obviously like someone recorded it with
her yeah I like how we use it kind of
like it was security cam footage and I
thought that was a smart way to edit
this into the trailer and man choosing
the right moments from movies like we
own the night I think anyone with a
hammer from I'm not really here and the
master of course like all these a
variety of performances then you're
looking at these other works of Joaquin
Phoenix sliced into here and you're like
yeah I'd be very surprised if Joaquin
Phoenix too bad job in this movie man
I'm super excited for this new Joker
movie solely just based on Joaquin
Phoenix and his yeah abilities as an
actor yeah just that just gets me it was
funny how like you look at the
trajectory of there's like the Heath
Ledger one of course and then you had
Jared Leto which people were very on the
fence about when he was cast most people
weren't really and then you hear but the
standalone Joker movie you're like
what's DC doing oh my god then Joaquin
Phoenix's caster like and you see a
little bit of his nuggets and moments
for the film you're like oh it's
probably gonna be amazing
I mean the Joker yeah what we alive well
I feel like if you bring all these a
hidden yeah if you've seen like
interviews of Joaquin Phoenix he's a
strange cookie he's a weird dude you
know that's for having fun is that
that's fun
I'll come to your house and shoot gunmen
on the red carpet and he's like did you
know that there's a small frog on my
head just climbing around in my head
it's crazy and you're like what large
frog in my hair no no something's
calling out on my scalp I was with the
guy where I'm like really off dude you
know it doesn't like interviews in
general but he's the kind of guy who was
- he likes to provoke he likes to troll
he likes to mess around and walking I'm
sorry you couldn't be here tonight and
if you're doing an origin movie of The
Joker we're gonna watch a guy evolve
into the Joker yeah and then you're
seeing all this other footage of him I'm
like yes I want to see all those
elements yeah I want to see the rage I
want to see I want to see like the
darker moments I'm still wondering what
his Joker voice is gonna be you know
like it's the big question that's the
big it's probably me normal voice you
see I'd be surprised if he did like the
high-pitched nasal voice that seems to
be the go-to voice the Mark Hamill the
Jared Leto the Heath Ledger has an
actually high-pitched voice though like
it's not granny's eyes he's a bit of a
soft voice he has a bit of a soft voice
yeah but I probably want like a deep
voice Joker all right don't be
open-minded at all and possibly ponder
what that means we can disagree it's all
right no we can't yes everywhere I go
it's a fight it's the way it works
you're always fighting sorry I caused
the scene because repressed emotions or
no there's a great trailer I love when
fans do this just the kind of like what
if sir yeah you know this is like a
fantasy someone's fever dream of like
what this what this movie could be it's
really well edited really well put
together people are talented man I mean
even if you took out the Joker moments
and you just did it as like a test
footage to be like here's what I think
walky face would be great let me show
you this like a closet
okay yeah he'd ever be the Joker yeah
especially with the like the scene where
he's like throwing the glass and
everything I think that's such a great
moment
dude the Masters so [ __ ] good it's a
great movie that's one of my favorite oh
yeah man it's an inspiring movie with
love yeah funny hilarious
it's just joaquin phoenix and philip
seymour hoffman being crazy together
yeah just their third acting I love it
yeah all right guys well thanks for
tuning in before we wrap this for you up
I would like to give a page of the day
shot at two let's see
hey choose any of these names other than
number ten
Victoria Huntley yeah Victoria Fayette
that's why I said ten uh we ruined them
all I'm sorry
oh no it's done begun no no we can do
this shout out Victoria Holly Victoria
Victoria Huntley Victoria Huntley lives
all the way in the U of the cave they
came to you she is engaged and she has
shown me photos of her and her
soon-to-be husband on Instagram fun I
have never touched myself to their
photos Stacey cannot get off to porn
ography she needs to know they are real
people who are really emotional arc yes
so I sent her your photos and it seemed
to do the job Stacey and her boyfriend
seemed to be having a much more dynamic
more engaging relationship now that
she's seen your guys's faces which is
made Paula you Mars pod oh dude you guys
are doing great out there she's also
really in Chinese food and Indian food
yeah so double date waiting for you guys
as soon as possible Stacey and I like to
keep things awkward to you we never know
how what we're doing is translating
through the lens of the camera but it
usually turns out fine I mean you know
you haven't kicked me off yet we'll see
subscriber to reject nation click that
notification about the Moulton festival
the Moulton's are my best friends I have
dinner with them every Friday night I
like to enjoy a good bottle of Hennessy
with them like this bottle of Hennessy
XL brought to you by the Ridley Scott
short film the seven worlds check it out
now yes yes yes and it goddamn yeah I
can if I can give Vince some more
friends don't want to be my friends well
see Jessie and her husband I'm trying to
have a double date with him for a long
time now with Jessie's husband's name
Rick no yeah Rick Scott I'm sorry Scotty
Rick Richard Scott you're so
embarrassing Victoria bye